don't suggest food or animals just
because that's too easy anyone can do
one set one second one second Canada
gosh for a stereotypically polite Nation
you interrupted straight there you're
like [__] Daddy no yeah but then they
apologize sorry
[Laughter]
I'll tell Justin about you guys
and if he doesn't do anything I'll tell
the Indian government and then they will
[Applause]
it's a remarkable number of people who
keep up with current affairs well done
I mean it's such a broad topic and I
would love to hone in on it so uh what
about Canada like not a stereotype
something about Canada do you think we
go we don't know right you know because
you guys are like you know we we go ah
maple syrup police ketchup flavored
crisps or chips whatever but like what's
something that they wouldn't know about
I once had an American
are all of your roads paved or not
they are
not they are well not all of them
no that's perfect the majority the
majority of the rules are peeved
yeah some people over there are like
I've been near Red Deer and Grand
Prairie it's not [__] mate
yeah I know I've I've done shows in that
place and it is [__] disgusting
literally it's amazing it's like one of
the easiest places to sell out because
nothing happens if you go there and
you're like comedy they're all like yeah
and they [__] you know put down their
hunting rifles and come along they don't
they bring them to the show so okay uh
unpaved Canadian road so let's come to
the the middle middle front of the room
this side oh yes yes
your stripper sister just turned 50.
wonderful
suggestion number two
I love it I love it it's your is your
sister here right now yeah [__] [__]
hell I'll see you after the gig yeah
Fifty Nifty
um back at the room let's go on from you
like we can't beat that Chris you don't
need to New Jersey what well again same
question with Canada tell us something
about New Jersey that's not just going
to be stereotypical hatred
the beaches are better
you got to pay for it but it's a cleaner
you've got to pay for it but it's
cleaner same with this just rip up um
[Applause]
the opposite isn't it
um okay so new New Jersey has cleaner
beaches 50 year old stripper sister
Canada's unpaved roads this side of the
middle front walks like a rapper
Germany okay um I mean again we're just
gonna keep shouting out regions
I want you I want you to make it extra
hard so pick something specific about
Germany
quiet
they're having a discussion that's what
all Germans do we have to form a plan
[Applause]
what what specifically we gonna do
okay I I didn't hear that shout it
louder
in Germany they are divided kids are
divided according to their performance
in Germany kids are divided according to
their performance
um okay I thought Eugenics was banned
but no
post-natal Eugenics okay cool
I mean it's quite common in certain
subjects the set system in the UK do it
for mathematics because you know some
people maths is a bit hard to say you
know they learn a different pace but you
know that's fine okay in this final
section no more country or state
suggestions uh let's get one final one
race horses racehorses I'm glad you
added the second word there
[Applause]
no he said horses thank Christ
okay well um I'm gonna ask my lovely
band to to to kick it off um but lay
down a beat we'll do a freestyle about
this we're rapping about race horses
about divided children in Germany New
Jersey pizzas beaches a 50 year old
stripper sister and Canadian unpaved
roads and if you don't like it it's your
fault you chose the suggestions so let's
let's have some fun
some things about the northern border
cousins that you didn't know it's out of
order to say that Canadian roads are
neatly paved like a hundred percent or
even 95 I've been to Alberta how the
[__] did I survive the bus driver was
swerving I was like who do I speak to I
need the person who takes care of the
Civics all of the inference structure I
gave him cheese curds he was like you're
in luck cause I love these he filled in
the potholes you were saying two girls
in the front roll coming from Canada
saying this is lovely you kind of butted
in tried to shove me but don't worry
later you apologized after the show
maybe you and these guys can go and hit
your sister's strip club up we can turn
in blow some helium balloons up with the
party hat we're starting that buying
shots for your 50 year old sister I know
she knocks Lots back but the drinks got
a large tolerance she can get a liver
out there and handle my friends I don't
mean sexually you're half a century take
a day off soon be a retiree spinning on
the pole showing all your breasts 50
years old well I wouldn't have guessed
probably got the Silicon implants take
the chance over there many years ago in
France the Germans were there they were
occupying if you say it's one class then
you would be lying because they make you
do tests what's your result if you're in
the lower set then it's your fault I'm
sorry to bring you a tiny Kinder you
should have written answers on the
inside of your fingers and that way you
can be more clever this is the type of
[__] that holds us together back in the
day we were fighting with the guns but
now we're rap battle in it's much more
fun D-Day Normandy we reach this the
Germans and British people on New Jersey
beaches but this time we're not putting
bullets in any horses New Jersey you can
go for a swim and the water it's much
cleaner much Bluer Manhattan Harbors
basically outfluence of sewers all the
way to there when the water come through
Storm surges seriously I agree with you
I'll take across the bridge or use the
PATH train when I swim in New Jersey I
never get in flame inflammation from all
of the horrible effluent you've got to
pay for it yeah I'm getting you in the
wrap as well the last one of course guys
shouting from his face he said race but
then horse and I was like Jesus Christ
I'm glad you say this horses I can be
mean to and not racist the white ones
they're the fastest the brown horses
they finish the lastest that's how we
are Rachel to horses you see what I mean
but Red Rum back in the day was living
the dream and sugar the fastest there by
far see biscuit Jesus Christ oh my God I
didn't know that I could name horses
three there we go shyama guys from
Germany
you guys are lovely my name is Chris
Turner thank you very much goodbye